[Music]
hey guys welcome back to another Q&A
video oh you guys ready
we actually got these questions from
that same Instagram post that I posted a
long time ago over a year ago was it
templates but yeah so we went back to
that old Instagram post and we pulled
these questions so if you guys want to
keep asking more questions or scroll
through my Instagram and then find my
notes and then post there cuz it's
easier than creating a whole new post
are you giving them homework scrolling
you know today we're gonna get started
on this Q&A here we pulled up these
questions I start for our first question
here by jaylen dot King for tip did you
think you would marry an Asian guy or
Casey did you think you would marry a
Mexican girl oh it's a union yang
question what do you want from me
yeah I never in my entire life ever once
ever thought I would even date an Asian
guy ever really yeah never so it's funny
that when people see us together they
I've heard comments before people will
be like oh she must like like Asian guys
or like or even in conversation people
will be like oh yeah so your other Asian
boyfriend I'm like oh hey they think you
have yellow fever yeah but no I mean I
thought you had yellow fever too you did
like them whenever I realized that you
were into me I was like oh most girls
that are dating another ethnicity you
can almost like 90% of times assume that
that person is kind of into that
specific ethnicity of whether it's the
culture or the type of person you know
it's like like if you're into black guys
are into black guys you're into white
guys are into white guys you know then
yeah there's a pattern most of the times
and you kind of break out of that no
I've never had a pattern or like a type
I don't know I just I think it's fine
again that was supposed to be your white
guy I was supposed to be your wife good
like the two previous serious
relationships I was in they were both
Latinos like one of them was Mexican
they was Peruvian and so after having
those relationships I'm like you know
what I want to try dating a white guy
like see what that's like so I actually
did have in mind like a certain
ethnicity that was planning on dating to
kick off my dating life because I had
always been in long-term relationships
and he was opposing me my first like
dating slash aflame
yeah like supposed to be a fling turn
out to marry my copy thing but yeah and
I yeah I forgot that I was supposed to
date like I was trying to date a white
guy on a white guy you are like I know
you born in Texas he's like super like
raised near white people and like you're
just the way you think it's like a white
guy he's just so funny cuz I pretty much
did get my white bag that's also
carbonation though I'm not white washed
I'm not I wash our banana it actually I
think it's usually banana okay sure
whatever banana tweet you thinking you
know what's interesting when we first
started dating I did have that thought
of like Oh dating an Asian guy because
when I first started hanging out with
like JK and everybody and a good chunk
of everyone that we were with was Asian
I had never really like did my past I've
never really thought about race that
much because I was always in I didn't
realize but I was like in my Mexican
bubble and so for me like if I had like
a black friend or white friend or an
Asian friend like in high school
I just thought in my head like oh yeah I
have a pretty diverse set of friends
like I know a lot of people but then not
until going out with you and your group
of friends and there's just nothing but
Asians I just I actually did feel like
outsider for the first time I was just
like whoa this is different and then
back then geo didn't tell me that she
was Mexican she was like trying to keep
her ethnicity a secret Trident vidual
yes I didn't even have heard of really
relate to so I just felt like the only
Mexican the only like completely just
removed from everything I had just never
felt that before ever in my life and
then it's funny because you say the
opposite you know I felt like an
outsider because I was never around
Asians to begin with all that much and
and not until I found JJ actually that I
felt oh this is what it feels like to be
around a lot of Asians and everything is
very Asian centric and then nine time of
to LA that I experienced like his la is
very interesting as a city you have like
pockets of an endlave an N clay meaning
like neighborhoods solely based around
certain ethnicities and there's no Asian
neighborhood there's Mexican
neighborhood there's the black community
there is no mineral community and Jewish
community yet it's not exactly a melting
pot although as a melting pot all the
pieces kind of stayed like I got
separated please yeah it's like TV
dinners that's la ya la and so I didn't
experience ethnicities like that and so
I moved here but then that's there's
something beautiful about that because
when you visit like Downey for example
like you're completely immersed in some
Mexican culture and when I started
dating you I didn't I never really
experienced like a Mexican neighborhood
like that that's funny now when I go
back in and visit friends and then now I
see the Mexican like neighborhood thank
you yeah like bubble I had never really
noticed that before because I was just
my whole life everywhere that I would go
to was also similar to that because I
would visit Mexico every single summer
so to me it was just like oh yeah this
is my world it's the same thing but yeah
I not until now I go back and everything
oh and then now I hear all my friends
accents and sometimes I'll look at
videos and from the pass and I'll hear
my own accent like whoa Deepti gonna
accent first time I was on the phone
with you like it surprised me like a
hardcore I was like wow I'm uptight I
just like we met at a bar in like for
some reason like I just never registered
an accent with you and then when I
finally got on the phone with you and I
had nothing like there's no face no
visual attraction at all she's just boys
and I was like am I talking yeah where
were you at you asked something - like
never never I always I mean I don't know
growing up Asian and living in an Asian
household like you would assume that
your future wife and the future life
would be kind of like a mirror image of
how you grew up and that was my comfort
you know just having something Asian and
so I thought well you know I'll probably
date around and you know explore and I'm
not like super like I need to have an
Asian girlfriend but I just thought that
my wife will be Asian though and not
that I'm actively looking for an Asian
wife but yeah I guess it wasn't about
ethnicities that at the end of the day I
was just finding the right person and
you were that person I guess and I don't
know it is pretty funny though that my
mom found a pattern amongst the girls I
used to date oh yeah really at least the
girls I used to like and I would talk to
my mom about like he's from
yeah that's the white part that's like
because most Asian kids don't talk to
their moms about the Kuro that they like
and I think my mom was very westernized
in this in this area of our relationship
and I would tell they're like I like
this room like this girl then she'd be
like oh yeah I'm noticing a pattern you
like darker girls oh really yeah like
brown girls I'm like oh yeah sure
because most a good destined for a mess
yeah oh yeah girl that liked a beninese
girl and they're usually darker too and
then now that I'm with you I'm like oh
and went darker am I like a dirty
Mexican and then you're not darker but
you're not exactly pale either it's like
that was a prophecy you are you were
waiting for a painting do how your
brother like Latinas - oh what's that
about yeah that was something that
crossed my mind but never actually got
to talk to him about it because I've
always wanted to be like don't you think
it's weird Carrie that he has brothers
we both have Mexican girlfriends and our
dad owns I don't know I think that that
might be a group discussion whenever we
go back to Dallas and we meet them all a
beginning yeah we talk about that yeah
we gotta talk about that all right next
question this one is from how you say
that name Amyris amorous a Mars whoo
what's one thing that you've taught one
another through the years maybe seeing
something a new way or learning a skill
whoa I know for sure you have changed
the way I view movies Oh 100% 100% I do
not view movies the same way any other
TV movies before I don't know before it
was just really like oh yeah like I
wouldn't
I don't analyze things I don't actually
like break things down as to why I like
something of Y I don't that's why when
people ask me like why do you like
skydiving
which is really fun like I don't
actually think about things like that
like analyzing it and so with movies it
was just like oh I didn't like that
movie why I don't know I just didn't
like it and then oh I did like that
movie cuz it was fun and that was the
only reason like I really didn't dissect
the movie like look at the moving parts
and see why it is the way it is cuz I
did grow up going to the movie theaters
a lot my dad used to take us back when
they were together my mom and dad were
together we still go every single
weekend to the movie theater and that
was like our tradition we would always
go and watch a new movie so like me
going to the movie theater it's I tie
that in with my dad a lot it's kind of
interesting I ended up meeting you and
like you love movies and it's kind of
funny too with my dad he had like Asian
obsessions ooh my dad would buy me
everything like yin yang like I had
changing earrings necklace like shirts
like just he would buy me Jeannie and I
got the blue he called him Chinese both
I don't know what they're called rotate
your ton of those pairs of those he had
a lot and then he loved eating the
ginseng drink root getting that's where
our dads my dad likes flatten stuff or
was he like do your children know he's
always like salsa dancing okay you know
what you're right like the older he's
gotten the more into Latin stuff he's
been but like but really like a child
and then like he always lit incense
everywhere I mean that's kind of agency
no I don't yeah for sure but yeah and
then like we still ice love watching the
Asian Channel and like
laughs sharing them Asian language I
don't even know which languages it was
but anyway the point is they're all
funny I forgot the point of this oh yeah
movie gum oh yeah oh there was question
yeah you've totally changed the way I
view movies now cuz now I see like the
cinematography like the lighting the
directing decisions like the acting
decisions like the character arcs like
all that stuff like now I know what dark
night of the soul means and say fat cat
and like all that stuff like you taught
me
I took the final movie for you to
homework something that I changed the
way you see I think you taught me how to
see life live no I think about it when
you found me I was you would you polish
the pen yep you found a dirty old penny
drop it into a puddle was rain and dirt
and it's just like covered in long hair
yeah yeah long hair don't care and you
know wearing a beanie to hold up the
hair and yeah lots of lots of stuff
going on yeah that's true like kind of
my work here yeah now it's just look at
her a conference but haven't you seen
how have I changed though you see
something like you view it that's the
that's a question here okay I was a
workaholic when you've met me and on
vacations I would always work you help
me scale back the Hey look I get it you
got a hustle you are a hustler respect
that but at the same time have some fun
enjoy life a little bit and you helped
me kind of don't take things so
seriously and so I think I like with TV
watching right yeah
from Mel Sun 23 where has been your
favorite place that you have traveled
together to what would be your top one
that's a hard one I want to say Paris
but I can't swear we got married I can't
fully say Paris because we haven't
experienced like I would like to
experience that City just the two of us
oh yes sure we were the times it was
pretty stressful who can do the wedding
related and then there was a lot of
people with us to all the time yeah
Isaac my parents and then the wedding
everyone else yeah so I would like to
say Paris but fitting Paris aside I
would say Barcelona because that's the
other one that that's the only place
you've actually been to or just two of
us no we went to Cancun we went to New
York they could eat talking about we did
go to Italy went to Naples Rome Florence
Venice Milan Lucca I only went to like
Sorrento and Capri and you have a good
memory I was like hell we went to Italy
it was like super super fun and I think
out of that trip my favorite destination
we went to was Venice that was just like
loving it so much know who's the best
there the sites were the best they're in
my opinion I love de Venice I think for
me it was Japan Japan yeah even though
it wasn't like I could romantic just you
and me kind of thing and like the entire
company JK was there and Isaac was there
that was the first trip that we went
together where I just was able to like
do what you said slow down and enjoy
life and don't worry and that was around
the time when you were like it's a rural
case you can't be editing we are on
vacation I tried making that rule front
since Cancun yeah it was like I got
really rich oh just like you're not
allowed to bring that lamp up like no
you kept that but actually after Cancun
was when they
really put my foot down because during
cancun the whole time there just saw
your butt it's fine to them after that
trip that's how oh it's like okay no
more pork no more work say no more work
on vacations yeah but I haven't haven't
been doing that that's why there's huge
gaps of no uploads yeah so application
you you know what there's actually gonna
be an upcoming very large gap of not
posting hopefully we unless I can hand I
can yeah hopefully we can plan ahead and
he can get his work done before we leave
but we're actually planning on going to
an anniversary trip and we're going to
Morocco so it's really exciting yeah I
wish we can answer this question after
Morocco because maybe more I was gonna
be our favorite I think yeah because the
what I see in my head and based on what
we're planning for this trip it's gonna
be awesome
and I can't wait and there's also
another trip right after Morocco we're
gonna be going to Austria and I am so
freaking excited about that like looking
at that country it just looks so
beautiful like I'm just so excited to
get to really explore it the heck out of
that place the same because like I
didn't even know it straight existed
before I heard learned about this trip
and I'm like oh cool well without you I
don't think I would have ever discovered
the existence of this place so let's go
forget like Croatia but yeah we're going
to Rocco in istria and then on the way
to Morocco
we're gonna be landing in Paris which
lands on the date of our sixth
anniversary and we're gonna be spending
the whole day in person that's gonna be
the first time we're gonna see the city
just the two of us as a couple that kind
of like what I was just saying earlier
and like bro Mia and wanted to see and
then on the way back from Morocco we're
stopping in London for a day and I've
never been there so I'm super looking
forward to that
fish and chips yeah and then and then
once we land in LA then we go to Istria
so it's gonna be a lot of traveling
checking things off on the baby bucket
list so I'm super excited cuz I'm
looking at all my friends having kids
and I'm still running
homo or you can call off the bucket list
in there no I gotta put my foot down I
want to see the world
boy the FOMO though I know I can see the
world with the kid in it but I would
like to see it just you know with what
the situation is right now without
throwing a baby in there yet okay so I'm
sticking to that I want to see landmarks
as I was even telling him like I'm so
down to just land at these landmarks I
don't want to see like just land there
see the thing and then leave like I'm
down for that too I know it's like it's
like a waste of travel and a great
journey though but it's just like boom
see it sigh let's go and then once we
have our kids and then everything's more
calmed down and like we're used to
traveling a lot that way to go back to
these destinations and actually fully
experience that place with our kids in
the future so that's kind of what I'm
thinking about the truth all right next
question from the brian tang what worked
Casey's parents first impression of
Isaac how'd they meet they have
established such a loving relationship
you know your parents are so wonderful
and they've been so open to loving Isaac
and treating them as one of their own is
just so like oh my gosh it just makes my
heart explode I love them so much but
yeah so there's first I'm crushed
what was their first impression you
would know that I I was so nervous I
like introducing the idea of dating you
and and dating someone that had a kid -
my parents don't like their Asian parent
yeah I mean I mean as s westernized and
as forward thinking as they are I didn't
know where this is gonna lead and I
don't know you know it's just I did I
didn't know and so when I when I finally
told them that hey like you know been
dating a girl that actually has a son
and you know I think it might be kind of
serious you know I'm really clicking
here and yeah I want to see where this
is gonna go
they're like okay cool I thought there
was gonna be like Casey watch out now
like you know this is yeah she was just
saying like yeah
are you sure like you know I she already
has a son like this is you know kind of
like he's done clean we she never used
words like that I think she kept the
very PC but yeah I guess she was she was
implying certain things like that but
that was a very short live moment it was
like I don't know like maybe like a
month or two of like kind of uncertainty
I wish it was like consistent about that
it wasn't like a one thing well I'm not
gonna I don't talk to consistently
either though so I think maybe like two
conversations over the course of two
months and by in the by the time I was
like you know I think getting more
serious and I'm just you know like a
fling in which what we were I mean in
the beginning we had established that we
were supposed to be a fling the two of
us knew that yeah I mean and it just
kind of made me ask the way to get into
a serious relationship one that works
start off with a frame for us I'm gonna
Monaco I give out advice out there and
everyone's like you guys said it would
work for us yeah so yeah it was a very
short live from my mom site and then my
dad which is really open about it he was
like oh cool all right can't wait to
meet him can't wait to meet her yeah and
then after like the two months of my mom
being kind of uncertain I don't know I
guess she she starts talking you push
him on Facebook and like Instagram or
whatever I don't know which she ended up
seeing pictures of Isaac and the head
she was like well you know what Isis
kind of cute he's a really cute kid I
really like pretty kids you know like
big eyes really nice smile and then he
died she has a really nice
you know he still doesn't even though
he's braces now he still has a great
smile but yeah isn't my mama like cute
kid and I just just kind of from
everything now there's kind of
snowballing towards us being more and
more together I think she just kind of
accepted it
the rest is history cool yeah it was
very open arms very surprised it took me
suppressed by surprise really because I
was ready to put up a fight I was like
let's go and car like I'm gonna make
this work and then after I got my I got
the guns and weapons already and it's
like oh okay good so before Casey's
parents met Isaac the night before cuz
they had flown into LA and they were
here for only a few days and I remember
we set up a dinner because I was like oh
you know like had to meet me first like
before the kids like you know just have
a meeting first so we ended up going to
k-town and we have like octopus life and
longer like life all this stuff now just
like so about it because I'm like I'm a
really adventurous kind of eater like
I'm still down to try anything once
everything came out twitching yeah like
deep deep deep down I'm like like are
they trying to see but they're not
Korean though I know but I like that the
fact that they're Korean but like the
fact that I don't know like this she a
picky eater I don't know like Asians
across the board no matter what Asian
you are like I think we love food and
we're very open to other people's food
I didn't know anything about Asian
culture period let alone like Chinese
culture or nothing I just I didn't know
anything about anything so well part of
me was like if this isn't sort of like
Asian test and how like I don't yeah so
then anyway so then we end up having
that really nice dinner I had such a
great time with your parents I'm like oh
my gosh they're so for you they're so
awesome they're super nice really really
down-to-earth really easy to get along
with like I just fell in love with him
to me
I'm like you guys are awesome what were
your expectations versus what you've met
who you met I didn't have expectations
okay
I think it's because I didn't really
know much about Asian culture so I
didn't even know what to expect at all
period we're so foreign and exotic right
no like I just knew us what dragons
stupid
I just mean my own Latin Mexican bubble
like I just know how to like I was just
trying to just be myself and not really
put up a front or anything I don't know
I was just I don't know I never the only
person that I know that never shifts in
social situations because most people
even including me I do too I catch
myself like shifting my certain quirks
depending on who I'm talking to and
you're the only person that I know and
that I've ever met in all my 30 years
that doesn't usually okay I'm not but
close enough
thank you I think that's a compliment
but yeah because in the end Street
funicula that's what it's you keeping it
real like my last name so anyway well
that's how I met your parents that's
just the way I went into it and I came
out just loving them to death already
from the get-go and so for the next day
when we met up with them again and then
this time I brought Isaac along make
French food yeah we ended up eating at a
French restaurant cuz he got married in
Paris and I was just telling Isaac just
being your best behavior okay like just
you know you're a good kid already like
it wasn't a lot of work for him to be on
his best behavior because he's already a
really good it was only four you know it
was just about to turn five exact you
cute kid yeah I miss that Isaac no we're
gonna miss this one to that no we're
gonna look back and say I miss
so we got to cherish every minute but
yeah honestly you know what's from that
night though it's kind of a blur cuz it
was really is a long time ago meaning
like I don't remember specific
situations and then I think the only
specific situation that I remember is
taking Isaac to wash his hands and I
don't know why that's like embedded in
my memory but I remember that night I
took him to the bathroom to co wash his
hand yeah I mean I don't I don't really
remember much about that it's just the
end yeah for some reason it's so random
I don't know why I remember that night
that was the first time where I don't
know why this is the whole
shape-shifting thing again I remember
that was the first time I opened up to
Isaac fully oh yeah yeah I think with my
parents being there to just create a
more of a family feeling in me and so
like I just finally opened up to Isaac
fully because before that it was still
more like you were really cool - yeah if
I remember he was just like really like
I was in and I do I think it kind of
freaked me out too it's like well you
know if this relationship moves forward
in any way then my relationship with
this guy moves forward - and I was kind
of freaking out with Loki I was freaking
out like what is that what is this you
know clarify though by the time you met
I think like I was obviously already
ready to like be committed to the
relationship with nothing I wouldn't
even introduced you to Isaac period
that's true
there yeah there was a time when we you
didn't let me mean eyes yeah if you
wanted to mean Isaac I'm like no like I
don't know where this is
yeah I didn't know what that would hold
for me and when I when it came my way of
like oh I see why you did have me mean I
said I don't know how to handle this
like weird transition for me so like in
my shoes I fully respected and
understood where you were coming from
but still like just from my perspective
I was just like come on dude like loosen
up a little like you know I I'm I am
introducing you to my kid and you still
have this like major wall it's like by
me taking that step I'm already telling
you like knock that wall down yeah you
wouldn't for like a long time no you
know what's weird too is like I think
I'm pretty good with kids all around
like I'm yeah used to teach comfort a
little yeah I got I've been I've been
around kids and you're teaching them and
even tutored kids before to psych ice
fell like uh-huh I'm pretty good with
kids but with Isaac it was it was hard
for me to open up for some reason
you know and I think I was the pressure
of the like the relationship and the
trajectory of it if it were to continue
and so I think that just made me close
up a little bit I think then that night
when we all kind of had dinner with my
parents I think that really helped me I
don't know you open up uh I don't know I
was able to kind of play with them and
like you know like baby talk with him a
little bit more and like you know I get
into his world you know I think before
it was more like oh he's in like his
five-year-old world and I don't know I
just couldn't bring myself to be in his
you know good like with kids you I can
order to really interact with kids like
you have to be on their level you know
and if you can't do that then you're not
speaking their language and then to this
day with ten-year-old Isaac it's it's
the same it's like you have to be in
ten-year-old Isaac world to really fully
communicate and if you don't you ain't
alienate him alienates you and it just
you know it doesn't work so yes that's
on the Adler yeah so what did they tell
you after they met I think that you love
do you guys they're like oh my god like
this is a beautiful mother-son
relationship beautiful mother beautiful
son and I don't know I just
think anyone's they menu everything was
like like there was no one more obstacle
in terms of what this could be no you
know I wish I would remember what date
that was I know the place though it's on
Sunset Boulevard yeah I only know the
place and but I wish I could remember
like even the month like when was that I
feel like it was near Christmas cold I
think it was well we were we were like
wearing some light jackets yeah yeah
started dating in me this might have
been like wait why did they come over oh
it's about my new car
oh yeah yeah yeah because at the time I
wasn't making enough money without a
cosign so my dad came over to help me
well he helped negotiate to a second
negotiating I think it was September
wasn't it yeah that's why we made it
official - actually that's when you
September in September when I was so we
started the fling in May and by citizen
every time filled by me though cause
it's like yeah the relationship started
time yeah September was when we said the
fling is off yeah this is full-on
boyfriend off right now yeah that's true
that's the September yeah yeah you know
we remember number of 2012 2012 a year
alright last question here's by SN g dot
SL hmm
what's the funniest thing I've said with
love from Belgium heart hearts love
woods okay I think I know what top of my
head because I really wish I would have
written down the funny things he said
when he was a toddler like he would come
up with the funniest things and I don't
know why I never wrote it down and I
hate myself for that but anyway I
remember one day he came up to us and he
was like mummy how come people say mega
so much and I was like what what do you
mean mega he's like yeah you know like
sometimes people would be like mega you
crazy
no way you just said this if it feels
like seven years old seven or eight
that's I like that oh my god I was
laughing so hard and then I was just
like this is too funny I have to record
this and I think I recorded I think it's
in my Instagram somewhere I was like
what did you say he was like mega you
crazy like you so in my day explain that
to Nicky I don't remember do we I think
we said something like we watered it
down baby don't say that you can cuz
that's not exactly what people say but
yeah just don't worry about that alright
guys thank you so much for watching this
Q&A video remember if you want to submit
your own questions for our next Q&A you
can either go back to my IG post which
is a lot of scrolling or you can just
comment this video and then I'll make
sure to check out this videos comment
section for future questions as well
thank you so much for watching you make
sure to LIKE and subscribe see you next
time you're crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]